Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number
you can call any time. Here is a call at
219 to David P about the Spanish channel.
Speaker 5: David Alan from Jersey, Please
stand every single day you keep promoting
the Spanish channel on the English Channel.
Speaker 1: Well, I didn't promote it today.
Speaker 5: I'm not interested in Spanish. I
don't speak more than a couple words experience.
I don't want Spanish stop promoting the Spanish
channel. But more importantly than that, anybody
that's listening to the English Channel can speak
English, so they don't need to go to the Spanish
channel because they already know English.
It's like it's like drive thru ATMs
that have Braille. You know, you say,
oh, it's great. You know, people who are
blind can use Braille, the 18 and the blind
person is going to drive up to the ECM.
Speaker 1: Okay. Beautiful analogy,
except it doesn't really work. So let me just
explain something here. I understand. Like,
I'm not blind to the reality that if you're
listening to this show in English, you
probably speak English. Great. Okay, Fantastic.
That being said, lots of people know others
who don't have the English language capacity
to take this type of content in in English,
but they do in Spanish. And so I have this
huge platform that I've spent time building.
And many of you know, people who would like a
Spanish version of the show. That's why I say,
Hey, we make a lot of this show now available
in Spanish for people who prefer that. And so,
for example, if you are a 22 year old whose
parents immigrated to the U.S. and they speak
conversational English but would rather political
content in Spanish, you can tell them, Hey, The
David Pakman Show that I listen to is available
in Spanish for you guys. So I don't know if you
know that that's more or less the explanation. All
right. We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Producer Pat is back. We will find out what he was
up to. We will talk about the impact of the fact
that police departments were not defunded, but
some have chosen to downsize. Why? What's going
on? We will discuss. Kevin McCarthy is telling
Americans don't protest. If Trump is arrested,
is Kevin McCarthy have the right idea? And lastly,
California has entered a contract to make its own
insulin and to make it affordable. We will talk
about how this will work, whether it will work,
and so much more on today's bonus show.
Speaker 4: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money and everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is back.
Speaker 1: Join me, my friends. Let's make
money on the bonus show. Sign up at join
Pacman dot com and don't worry, we will be back
tomorrow with a new show. You'd better believe it.